joining me in the studio is Matias bike
investor and author of the book the
crash is the solution why the ultimate
collapse is coming and how you can
protect your wealth Matthias thank you
very much for joining us today tell me
more about your extremely pessimistic
views and and and why you think a crash
could be the solution dan not extremely
pessimistic they're realistic I'm not a
pessimist I'm a realist and if we see
what's going out there nothing has gone
better since 2008 we just tripled the
global bet death from 100 trillion to
300 trillion so we paid that with new
debt and that won't work out it's a
mathematical problem we should solve it
now otherwise the crash will be the
solution what about Europe as a whole
though just concentrating on the
eurozone there's a banking Union in
place Greece has managed to keep its
head above water there's growth there's
growth right throughout the eurozone
it's minimal but the problems are being
tackled one after the other do not think
that we're on a path that could get us
somewhere or do you think it's far past
that it's far pasta for example Greece
is Greece is bankrupt what is the super
latif of bankrupt there is not such a
thing so we have to relieve Greece out
of the eurozone we have to help them and
support them but they need their own
currency the same problem I see in
France in Spain in Portugal the euro is
far too strong for them and far too weak
for us it's a money problem as well well
talking about money what about the costs
involved of an entire country going
bankrupt the consequences as well as far
as a domino effect is that something
you've factored into your book as well
yes the cost will be immense but wet
better we finish it now and start from
scratch then building up more and more
and more depth and the costs in the
future will be much much higher but we
can't solve the problem by printing
money what we're doing at the moment so
we're only talking about greg's at the
moment we've we've got the brig's it as
well which is happening or what if it
then comes to a frigid and then it'll
exit it will come
two fractured into an it alexic if we
look at the country's the economy is
worse than before entering the Europe
they've got very high unemployment rates
and that would be better off with their
own currency we need a strong economic
union in Europe otherwise we'll be lost
but we can't have the same currency in
states like grease on the one side and
Germany on the other side that won't
work out so if the drachma comes back if
the lira comes back what happens do we
have a solution overnight or does it
mean years and years and years until we
get back to perhaps where we were oh we
lose probably a decade but if we don't
stop it now we lose much more we're just
building up piles and piles of depth and
there's no solution the European Central
Bank is printing 60 billion per month
we've printed 1.5 trillion where should
we go Matthias we'll get back to you on
that question in a moment first let's
take a look at the situation for the
Greeks they're tired of the constant
stream of new reforms none of which
seems to be doing the trick the result
strikes and protests around the country
which are increasingly ending in
violence
[Music]
shush
goss Ravi it's a catastrophe we can't
produce anything the government has to
go we don't want it anymore they're
traitors and gangsters they don't want
us to work they want to kill us off they
want to throw us out of Europe so what
is the reality for the Greeks are we
putting the Greeks we being Europe on a
lifeline which in any case could be
cruel or or is there genuine help for
the Greeks at the moment at the moment
we don't help the creeks we student
safety Greeks resolve the money we save
the banks will lend at the Greeks the
money but we should support the Greek
people if over 400,000 young people
leave the country a country without a
youth has no future so we really have to
support Greece and not the banks has
grease changed in any way I mean they're
getting huge amounts of money from the
EU before the crisis a lot of them were
living the life yeah it has changed but
now it's going backwards if you're
looking at the health system and all
that stuff that's going backwards and
backwards and the people are getting
worse and worse off so the solution is
to go back to the drachma to set up what
a multi-speed Europe or what would you
like to see for Greece and they will
never ever paid at that Germany is the
superpower and we don't pay a single
cent back so the crease will never ever
pay anything we have to release the debt
and then we have to support them and
support the economy like Germany head
after the Second World War so-called
marshall plan if we don't do that the
country will staff more and more and
more and more people will leave the
country but ears like man with some
drastic measures for a drastic situation
thank you very much for coming in today
thank you